well campaigning in the run-up to the
u.s presidential election has ramped up
with donald trump holding packed rallies
in
florida ohio and north carolina
meanwhile democratic candidate joe biden
addressed his supporters at
a drive-in rally in pennsylvania more
than
50 million people have already cast
their ballots and even trump himself
took advantage of early voting
with his ballot cast in florida a
frenetic day on the campaign trail was
underway thank you very much and you're
going to be very busy today
because we're going to work you hard
this pleasant who did you vote for
today i voted for a guy named trump
thank you very much everybody next stop
another swing state we will
make america great again thank you north
carolina
good luck but polls are showing four
more years in office are far from being
a sure thing for trump
and every vote counts in the race
especially in
battleground states like ohio trump's
third destination of the day we have
done more
in the first three and a half years that
any administration has done
the state has been hard hit by the
coronavirus and trump
asked people to wear masks and socially
distance
advice given to a crowd reversed to his
recommendations
it was a different story in joe biden's
native pennsylvania where the democratic
candidate
focused on health care complications
from covert
will become the next pre-existing
conditions allowing insurance companies
to jack up your coverage
and women are going to be charged a hell
of a lot more for their health care
just because they're women look
donald care donald trump thinks health
care
is a privilege i think it's a right
in florida the biden campaign called in
the help of former president barack
obama
who slammed the trump administration's
handling of the pandemic
[Music]
but the idea that somehow this white
house
has done anything but completely screw
this thing up
is nonsense after ohio the trump
campaign headed to another swing state
wisconsin
poll show biden is leading there but
trump isn't giving up
with a little over a week until election
day the race for the white house is
entering
its final stretch
well india has launched its month-long
festival season with prime minister
narendra modi urging people to take
precautions against the coronavirus
though daily case counts are down by 40
since their peak in november modi called
on indians to show restraint when
celebrating in the midst of the pandemic
and this has led to new and safer ways
of observing the festivals
the hindu festivals of durga puja and
ducera
are taking place in a dampened way in
india this year
pictures of crowds appearing on social
media have sparked fears that the
festive season could lead to a deluge of
new coronavirus infections
india has the world's second largest
number of confirmed coronavirus cases
after the united states
but infection rates have halved since
the country reached a peak of 100 000
daily cases last month
nonetheless this year's celebrations are
palpably muted
and many prayers have gone digital
organizers have decided to live stream
many sessions
for devotees to watch from the safety of
their homes
we are organizing this puja so that
nobody should come here
only virtually we just doing the puja so
online people can see it from their
house
and there only they can do the puja
food blessed by the goddess durga is
being home delivered so people
don't gather to eat in public spaces
everybody has their own problems
and they always come to the goddess and
ask for help
but this time we are all equal we are
asking for
kobe to get rid of kobit in many states
barricades have been erected around
usually buzzing places of worship
the hindu festival season will culminate
with diwali
the festival of light of which
socializing is an
intrinsic feature but this year
covert 19 is casting a shadow over the
festivities
and here's a look at the latest
developments in the global coronavirus
pandemic
spanish media reports that the
government has approved a nationwide
state of emergency to
combat soaring covet 19 case numbers
the move enables authorities to impose
curfews and other measures
daily new coronavirus cases in hungary
have topped 3 000
for the first time but the government of
prime minister victor orban is seeking
to avoid a repeat of
last spring's lockdown and the uk is
looking at reducing self-isolation
periods for people who've been in
contact with
infected persons britain currently
requires a 14-day quarantine
for those exposed to the virus
you